why does everyone hate on getting rich
quick get rich quick schemes are the
best
i want to get rich quick i don't want to
get rich slow
[Music]
it's actually colder here than the
arctic circle
why do you live there
well i mostly live in miami irs if
you're listening to this but i'm
sometimes in a mountain town
in the middle of nowhere
uh sam i saw you posted today
that you've got about 20 acres in texas
but i'm staring out at 95
acres of arctic winter winterland right
now is that cool or no i mean i love i
love it out here i'm from i'm from here
so for me it's
it's uh it's slow living it's nice um
yeah i love it is that why you look like
a pilot right now in the cockpit or
what's going on here
[Laughter]
i mean
sahil makes sao blue my co-host on my on
on the weird happens pod
we we do it together and he always makes
fun of this but i'm a gamer so i'm not
afraid i'm not afraid to admit it be who
you are man be who you are
uh
greg so you're here because i don't even
know why you were talking we weren't
even i don't even know what we were
saying we were talking about the will
smith thing
you had some hot takes sam had some hot
takes
how can we start with anything else but
the [__] slap of the century
will smith [__] slaps chris rock for
making fun of his wife
we i think we have a different opinion
on each one of these things sam give me
your first where were you when it
happened how did you hear about it what
was your first take i was laying in bed
and i hear sarah goes oh my gosh you've
got to come down and watch this this is
crazy and i saw it and here's the thing
by the way do you just go or do you wait
you ask what is it no i go right away i
can just go all right that's the good
guy right there so here's the thing
listen
i tweeted about this right away people
were like well what would you do the
truth is
maybe the same thing
i maybe would do the same thing but
that's wrong and if i would have ran up
there it bitch-slapped chris rock i
would have been tackled and taken away
and he should too that's what should
have happened
i wanted to see him tackled and taken
away or at least
not allowed to be on stage for five
minutes to accept an award that is
ridiculous to me i could not believe
that happened
greg give me your where were you what
was your initial reaction
so
my girlfriend texts me and she's like
you're not gonna believe what just
happened will smith just slapped chris
rock and then she's like wait i don't
know if it was a slap maybe it was a
punch and so there was this confusion
there was this like five minute
confusion where people didn't know what
it was
so first place i go to uh is on twitter
i'm on twitter
and i i i looked at the video and i was
like i couldn't believe it was happening
right it was like you remember when um
janet jackson with the whole super bowl
thing yeah like i feel like i remember
what where i was with 9 11. i remember
what happens when the janet jackson boob
incident of the super bowl it's unlike
oj and then
smith yeah now will smith
so
i
wasn't happy with the videos that were
coming out
but i found the japanese and australian
videos did you guys see those
for sure
the uncensored uncut versions
yeah
yeah and and that one where uh
you got a better view of the punch
you know i needed a better view it was
it was a slap though i don't know how
good your view was it was a slap
it was yeah okay it was a slap
but what bugged me about the whole thing
and i'm glad you invited me to talk
about will smith because you know that's
why i'm here
is
i think that okay obviously
it was a douchey thing of will smith to
do
but i was
unimpressed with how chris rock
wasn't able to make a joke of the whole
thing and he could have made comedic
history and he didn't
and
i expected more from him wow
disappointed with chris rock that is not
the take i thought was gonna come that's
why we bring greg on for the the when
everybody zigs you zag with the new take
disappointment dude chris rock crazy
impressive he took it man
he took it he didn't tear up he didn't
like when you get punched in the face
sometimes you're not like crying but
your eyes water none of that happened he
kept smiling and he was a pro man
sam you know what happens if you get hit
in the side of the head what's the first
thing that you feel right here
you your ears hurt and you want to like
grab your face yeah you you hear this
ringing buzz and like the sound you hear
this just giant ringing and then you've
got to touch your face he didn't touch
his face that
you got to give him respect for the chin
that he shared yeah the round was that
was a 10-9 chris rock round but then
greg's right actually
he had i mean the world was his oyster
with all the potential jokes that he
could have gone with the one-liners like
i can't believe i can't believe they had
you and ali or something like that
exactly
you know i don't even know what the joke
should have been you know greg what
direction would you have gone with the
joke
uh i would have said
and the winner to the biggest
uh
[__] slap award 2022 goes to
william smith
yeah exactly could have given him the
oscar for [__] of the year wait but
honestly
what was your take though
okay so i'm i'm outside of a cold stone
just gave my daughter some ice cream
we're trying to get back to the car i
don't know if you know how it is getting
kids in the car is like
that's the battle every day that's
that's the battle in fact there's a
great louis ck joke where he's like
the greatest moment of any father's day
is the like 30 seconds from when you
close the door and you have them in the
car seat and you walk around the car
back to the driver's car seat it's like
the 30 seconds of peace that you have in
that moment that's everything so i'm
trying to get in the car and my wife is
stopped she's stunned she's doing the
like oh my god face looking at her phone
almost to it was like a cartoon
character and i was like what it can't
like whatever it is it can't be can't be
much
and then she was like no will smith just
punched chris rock i was like what
and so then i watched the video
she made me pull over we were driving i
pulled over to watch the japanese
uncensored version because we just had
to like debrief it in the moment
and um
i was team will smith i thought it was
awesome frankly the only part that i
thought was not cool
the only part i thought was not cool was
that when they first said the joke he's
laughing at the joke
so bro you can't laugh at the joke admit
that it's funny and then basically two
seconds later
build up this rage and then pretend it
was so
uh not cool when it was you were
laughing like we caught you on camera
laughing wait two seconds before that
you don't think that he should have any
consequences
no no i didn't say that he should have
come sure okay sure lock him up throw
away the key whatever you got to do no
no
jail time i don't even think i'm not i
don't even want i don't want handcuffs i
don't want jail just like a hey will you
can't hit someone you gotta leave like
that would have been that would have
been sufficient well the thing they
showed uh in the uh i don't know the
taiwanese
cut they had the commercial break i
don't know if you guys saw this
somebody comes running up to him i think
oh wow they're gonna be like dude what
the [__] we need to get you out of here
sorry
it's his publicist just immediately
giving him notes on how to
play this and so when he goes up for his
speech what do you know the first line
he says is you know richard williams was
a fierce like protector of his family
that's the publicist handing him the
feeding of the line of how how are you
going to spin this to your advantage who
hates a guy who protects his family
i think it worked
i watch his speech i think he's losing
it so in a way i feel sorry for him i i
definitely feel a little sorry he looked
a little off right he looked a little
off he looked like he's kind of
he's getting a little a little
something's going on and i hope he could
i hope he works through it and gets back
and also there dude him and his wife man
that's some weird stuff like what's
going on like hey did you see that thing
called red table that her show where she
just like did a whole show with him on
there talking about how she cheated on
him and everything like that and then
she went i don't know
but i watch everything that's trashy
like that so yeah i saw it i saw it
twice man so like that's weird to me a
little bit so uh there's like a butt
this dynamic is was weird he's got a lot
of pressure on him i think he just kind
of snapped i think he's working through
some stuff but dude but so i feel like
everybody
everybody knows a couple that's like
this where they're like kind of toxic
they're like toxically in love with each
other it's like they got some weird
bunny and clyde [__] where they're like
they kind of like
they like make the wrong decisions
sometimes they even like you know hurt
each other's feelings but then they're
like if anybody else ever tries to
encroach they like will murder for them
and it's like bro where's the balance
here
it's like us against the world they love
this like us these us against the world
couples and they're definitely one of
them
yeah it was messed up do you want to
talk about uh alex hermozy
her mozzie mosey yeah what did you do
you were like
bro i'm going deep on alex from aussie i
was like we are so would have been nice
to do before we had him on the pod you
do it like 10 episodes later
i had a call with him today greg do you
know who this guy is
i don't know who's that all right
actually i feel bad i consider him a
friend but i don't i don't know if it's
pronounced mosey or mozzie alex hermosie
is it no mozzie alex
it's one of those things where it's like
two like you've known him for a decade
yeah and it's like you can't ask him now
you no you got to be like i just call
him moz i just go by maz because
dude one of my best friend's name is
sieve i don't even know how to pronounce
his last name um so and i've been best
friends with him for 10 years he's in my
wedding um so anyway this guy alex so
basically he had this company called
gym launch and it was really interesting
because some people and i wouldn't call
myself totally on that side but i
understand it is it appeared a little
scammy but actually i don't think it's
scammy at all anymore he ended up
waiting sam you've got to describe the
guys look first so he's got he looks
like a straight version of the
construction worker in the village in
the village was it the village people i
mean he looks like a construction worker
so he wears flannel he's got this
beautiful thick mustache long awesome
hair like a like a persian samson and he
is just yoked he's jacked he's huge and
he's like good looking and he just
he's like looks like arnold
schwarzenegger a little bit
and he created this business called gym
launch
and basically you would pay either four
thousand dollars for one thing or twenty
thousand dollars for another thing and
it was for people who owned small gyms
whether that's a crossfit gym or a
personal training gym
and he would basically teach you how to
make your gym better because he owned
gyms and he would promise you something
like uh you'll gain at least 75 000 in
new revenue but for a lot of people he
averaged that they would improve by 200
000 in revenue
but the business model that he had was
crazy and the results were even crazier
so the business was by the time the
business was four years old he
bootstrapped it and had paid himself 45
million dollars in dividends and then on
the fifth year i believe he sold it and
he netted something like 50 or 60
million dollars and so he was like yeah
i paid myself 45 million so i had about
25 million just in cash in the bank then
we sold and i netted like another 50.
and that story alone is crazy is that
right sean
i don't know if those exact numbers are
right it sounds like you talk to him so
let's go with that i i don't really know
but but yeah but you you got the
the product right the the the kind of
the hook or what's interesting is
most gym memberships are like you know
pay 20 a month and you get into a
membership and like it's hard to sell
people that and what he was ended up
doing was he was like all right well
people don't want a membership what do
they really want they want to lose
weight they want to lose weight in six
weeks or less they want to lose weight
so they look good on the beach all right
so i'm gonna basically sell you a
program
that's going to make you look good on
the beach in six weeks and he like he he
got good at selling for his own gym
where he's like oh i can get people to
pay like three grand up front for like a
fitness training package with nutrition
meal plans and stuff like that
and then someone pointed out to him i
think like russell brunson or whatever
the clickfunnels guy pointed out to him
like
hey dude instead of just opening gyms
and doing this yourself you should just
teach other gym owners how to do this
like that's a better product
is helping a gym like add 100 grand in
revenue in 30 days is a better product
than like trying to open your own gym
and use that method so then he started
doing that and then that's kind of how
he went now we own something called
acquisitions.com where he'll like buy
your business if you're doing i don't
know five million or more revenue
something well so he's buying course
businesses and like applying his
methodology and so but basically what he
sold was
and this is where things got i went deep
on i was like how did this work this is
crazy so he basically sold
not a franchise but like an operating
system and so he used hubspot as his
back end and he would get people to sign
up to these ads that he was running and
you do an on-boarding and you pay 20
grand you get four months then after the
end of four months you can decide to
stay in part of the group and it's 45
grand a year but you get this after you
sign up uh you get this checklist of
things that you have to do so it's like
raise your price to this sign up for
this software use these emails this
shrimp campaign get them get this many
people to sign up by doing x y and z
here's the ad campaign that you can just
copy and paste in order to use and
then he had a facebook group where all
the members could talk and that was it
that was the business it was super
simple and it was doing tens of millions
a year in revenue and also tens of
millions in profit and i thought this
was crazy fascinating and i wanted to
ask you guys what other
he told me a little bit but what other
niches would you use this for and also
does this model even interest you it
seems pretty amazing to me i've never
heard of it
i think that if you did this for
agencies like digital agencies
that this is a no-brainer so
you know
we're
i run an agency called late checkout
we're about 50 people
uh so we're starting to really hit some
scale
and
you say your revenue
uh
i mean
i don't want to say my revenue but we
have 50 people so you can do some of the
math yourself
um
[Music]
i will say that
um yeah we work with some of the biggest
brands in the world and it's very lonely
to be like this
ceo of an agency like i don't know if
i'm over charging or under charging i
don't know if i'm
you know
you know doing the right thing should i
be doing more marketing less marketing
so like would i pay two five ten grand a
month to for like
something like this like probably if the
roi is there
yeah it's basically a sales machine
right so what each what he said was if
you have a business and you have
whatever number of customers you have if
i could get you more customers that's
clearly of value to you and i think he
basically tried to get like
capture 10 to 20 of the value that he
was giving so you know if
if i'm gonna if i'm gonna generate a
hundred thousand dollars in new
incremental sales for you how do i
capture 10 to 20 000
and i and i'm taking the risk if i don't
do that then i don't earn anything i
think that's kind of how he started it
at least and so agency is a perfect one
like that because every client you sign
is cash in the bank and uh typically the
agency might be good at one thing but
not necessarily good at going getting
new clients so what uh
you just read this guy's book sean
alex's book i'm reading right now what
do you think about it
the book is good uh the book is good
it's basically a
it's like a marketing book right so it's
a it's essentially a marketing book he
does a good job of breaking things down
being simple
it's not all together new information
but um
but who gives a [__] it's like it's good
information presented well and if you're
running a business right now it'll help
you now the thing i think that he over
indexes on is like
he uses like the gym launch example
really hard so it's like yeah this this
is clearly he talks about basically he
says you
the secret to sales is make somebody an
offer so good they'd be stupid to refuse
you okay how do you do that it's like
how do you get them to perceive that
there's a lot of value
and that they're going to get in a short
amount of time with a with a with not a
lot of cost
and that it's highly likely to happen
and so his model was like
hey gym owner i on i work with 100 gyms
on average i can bring them each 100 000
in new sales
i can do that for you in 30 days and if
i don't do it if i don't hit that mark i
don't get paid how's that and so yeah
that is what he calls a grand slam offer
because it's gonna work and if if you
have a grand slam offer you can win a
lot of business you can grow very fast
but i don't think that works in a whole
bunch of other product categories so i
think it works in the like agency
consulting world which is where he was
it's services i think it works services
all services you know if i'm selling
shoes online it's very hard to
create a grand slam offer for selling
shoes because uh you know
i can't tell you how much more money
this is going to make you right so
already the offer is a lot less i'm
telling you it looks cool you know that
people might like your shoes that's just
fundamentally less compelling so i just
think it's like really really good for a
service business um especially a service
business that's in the business of
helping other people make money but uh
like if like for example i wanted to
send it to my accountant and be like hey
you're charging me like five grand or
six grand a year
you should really be charging 50 grand
and if you did this method i think you
would have you know like 10 times more
clients and make 10 times more money off
them
if you presented your stuff this way
because you're an accountant you're
saving people money on taxes and you
could basically offer a no-brainer offer
like this and take more value and grow
your business faster if you did it this
way but um
it doesn't work for everything it's kind
of the takeaway
i think i think the
the pitch is
is taking a consultancy from a
consultancy and turning it into selling
luxury
like
that's the opportunity for a lot of
these people right like i think uh when
you look at mckinsey mckinsey isn't a
consultancy to me mckinsey is selling
like a luxury multi-million dollar
contracts like that you're buying
confidence when you're buying uh
right a luxury product
yeah that's exactly right he talks about
that uh pretty extensively in the book
but i gotta say so i i am reading this
book and i have two kind of like
my two like my right hand man and my
left hand man i have i've been and then
i have this guy andre and
i told him i was like guys is this good
stuff in this book that we should be
using uh and so i created like a little
mini book club inside of our company to
do this have you guys ever done that
like have you basically and i've been
wanting to do this with podcasts as well
sometimes i'll listen to a podcast
that's like [__] amazing
and i what i want to do is just stop
listening to it myself and be like hey
guys we're gonna do a meeting but the
meeting is us listening to this podcast
and every time they say something good
i'm gonna pause and we're gonna talk
about it and it might take us like six
hours to get through this one hour
podcast but i'm telling you it's gonna
be we're gonna actually apply the thing
versus just i share the link you read it
i read it we each kind of move on with
our day and we're busy have you guys
ever done anything like this to like get
more
juice out of the fruit
i haven't i haven't i've done a book
club
uh
that
i feel like book club is it's like you
know a lot of people go in the gym it's
like you start going to the gym and then
you kind of like stop like
it's really hard to create a really
well-designed book club that keeps
people engaged
yeah we did book club it was the same
thing no one [__] finished the book
so i actually think if we all just
listen to a podcast together it might be
a lot easier it's a lot easier it's like
when you go to school and the teacher
brings in the tv uh that's like how i
would feel going to this meeting i'd be
like oh hell yeah
we're rolling in the t-bag
magic school bus baby the um
yeah at amazon they do this too where
like uh people write all kinds of docs
inside companies like memos plans
whatever
and then it's like hey did you read my
plan and then you're like oh yeah either
i kind of did or i didn't very rarely is
it like i read it i remember it i took
notes on it and i'm ready to take action
from it and so at amazon they basically
hacked that process which is the rule is
you have to write if you're going to
make a plan if you're going to try to do
anything you have to write your memo
but the memo gets read in the meeting
itself so every meeting if it's an hour
the first 10 to 20 minutes are silent
reading everybody reads it together at
the same time and there's zero
expectation for you to ever read
something beforehand or afterwards
oh yeah it was it was huge uh like and
also while you're reading your you know
you're taking notes because you know
right after this reading period ends in
20 minutes like
it's a bit like school it's like i'm
gonna have to have something to say
right like i need to have i need to be
bringing something to the table from
this and so um yeah that was huge and i
think i think way more companies should
do that it was like one of the few big
company things that i was like this is a
process that is so much better than what
i used to do at
our startup
yeah well i think that podcast idea that
you just had is actually fantastic
um cool all right we lost greg for a
second but let's let's keep going um did
you have anything more on hermize or you
wanted it to go on no that's it what do
you got i was thinking about doing like
a kind of like a summary slash lessons
learned because i have a whole bunch of
like screenshots and highlights from the
book i might do a separate pod that's
just that if you want to do that um
i just i just i just bought the book
i've been watching a lot of his youtube
videos there's just something about this
person he's very interesting to me he's
very interesting he's so transparent to
the point where it's weird almost like
it's like i i like he reveals so much i
don't believe you
uh no i believe him i believe him for
sure but he's revealing so much that i'm
like are you sure man you want to be
talking about this this is crazy like
you like it's just weird it's just weird
right i mean he talks like i don't think
it's weird i think it's smart and that's
why i say like do i believe this it's
not that i think he's lying about
anything i think he's telling the truth
it's that
when somebody is that forthcoming it's
sort of like well what's in this for you
and i think clearly it's
i'm trying to get you to trust me uh
and so i'm going to be like kind of like
explicitly
transparent about something because i
there's a there's a motive behind that
and i think that's okay uh but i think a
lot of people like wow
thanks dude for the favor it's like
there's no favors um people do things
because they have a motive they want to
build their brand in a certain way they
want to attract more more readers or
viewers or they're trying to build trust
in a way so that they can get some
advantage you know that's okay i think
that's a it's a good thing i i do it too
i do it all the time yeah um
yeah i've gotten to know him over the
past few weeks i'm a fan man i'm a fan
of alex's but what do you got
uh well actually we should so greg i i
told you bring three or four bullets i
don't know if you had time to do that
but i have some if you don't have any
but i'd like to use yours if you do
because you're here you're the guest of
honor yeah i mean i always have a notes
file with some ideas i can tell you i'm
not going to say they're great ideas but
let's let's start with that and i love
your feedback
all right let's do it
um so
i went to a restaurant
two nights ago
saw that a bunch of kids were playing
these like picture like an applebee's
and
picture a bunch of vending machines um
like you know those games that you can
play
i'm thinking
vending machines
so
you have to pay like 100 doge to get in
you can win a board ape
instead of winning you know
collectibles you're winning digital
assets is there a business to be created
around that
you're talking about the thing where you
would like
the old way is you you know you put your
quarter in and there's a bunch of
plastic balls you get one out you got
this little shitty toy and it's like i
think in japan they call these the
gotcha games is that right like gotcha
mechanic where you have this sort of
variable reward you might win the good
thing but you almost never win the good
thing and then you kind of keep wanting
to open up these boxes and see what you
get
exactly that but with doge
and winning
nft's inside
greg do you own any nfts are you on
board with us or no
yeah i mean
i've got hundreds of nfts
that's crazy
yeah
i
i think the problem is doge i think not
enough people own doge um you know so i
i kind of feel like it's like you need
to apple pay to quickly like
instantaneously buy doge and then use it
use it in the game basically like you
need some way for their phone to just
buy the thing and then just keep swiping
their phone yeah i guess like what i'm
particularly interested in here is like
what are
you know in real life experiences that
you can create that connect with crypto
um
yeah another version of this by the way
because i don't need at restaurants
anymore i just deliver everything so
it's like
um
you know a qr code that comes with
doordash that i just scan and i get to
play the game on my phone right like why
do they need to buy a screen
when i carry a screen in my pocket so
like really all you just need is a qr
code to do this game you don't even have
to build the you don't even have to
build the vending machine necessarily
it's true it's true
um all right i got another one so
i uh moved out of my apartment december
15th it's now
march 28th
and my landlord
hasn't returned my security deposit
is that in america or it's in florida
yeah miami ooh
there's a bunch of laws around that
california well there's laws around it
in in florida too and i googled it and
there's a whole process you can go into
it i'm sure it's
probably not as intense as california
but you know you have certain rights um
there's a whole process that you have to
go and eventually you go to small claims
court et cetera et cetera
how much was it
uh it's a few hundred dollars but it's
just like the pain to like go through it
it's not really worth it my security
deposit is fifty seven hundred dollars
um so what i really wanna do is scare my
my landlord basically
right that's what i wanna do so i want
him i need to get his attention that's
what i really need to do
um so i googled
um
you know sending a lawyer letter i
didn't want to call my lawyer because i
was like at 750 an hour or whatever it's
gonna cost like two grand for this
lawyer letter so the idea is
a
lawyer letter on demand go scarif go
scare someone basically
what do you think have you um i love it
so listen we got to talk about this
shawn you know where where i'm going to
go with this right
do not pay you're going to petty court
well i like penalties
but i'm going to go do not pay great
have you not heard of do not pay
yeah so is do not pay that service that
like if you have a parking ticket you
like send it to them and
they like
they deal with it and you get a
percentage of it back or something like
that
they do a bunch of stuff but that is one
of the ways how they started how do you
explain this company now sean now that
it's kind of they have so many features
yeah i think it's start it basically
it's it's just trying to save you money
from [__] that you you shouldn't have to
pay for you don't want to pay for so it
started with like
subscriptions you're not using all right
cool unsubscribe me from a bunch of
subscriptions i'm not using then it
became
yeah then they also added you know like
go contest this parking ticket because
like i don't know 20 or 30 of parking
tickets are like filled out incorrectly
and you actually shouldn't have to pay
and if we save you money we will keep a
little bit but it's just you do no work
and you'll get they just keep a portion
of the savings that they get that they
earn for you
and then they expanded into like
83b election like hey we'll do that for
you for your startup so they're just
like trying to do they're basically just
trying to eliminate the busy paperwork
that nobody wants to do
and they're like we'll just take care of
that [__] for you how would that feel
and a bunch of like people like us
were like millennials were like i just
don't know how to do it i don't want to
do it i don't like printing things or
going to the post office and like doing
all this [__] yeah please take care of
this for me so it's a time saver company
is how i think about it and greg i had a
landlord i had a 16 000 deposit this was
for our office uh when covet
our office lease just so happened to end
right around when kovid was happening so
we got really lucky and we just
cancelled it and this guy would not give
me the 16 grand i found out dude i got
crazy on him i found out where he lived
did i showed up at his house and he
wasn't there i found out where he worked
and i showed up there and he wasn't
there and i used do not pay to send him
like a like a letter and finally he got
back to me it was like oh yeah you know
just slipped my mind like he was like no
big deal about it and i was like dude
i've been howding you for six weeks man
where's this money and so they they have
that feature where you just send a scary
letter you send a scary letter and uh it
worked and so uh we we i got my 16 grand
but legally you're supposed to get 16
grand plus interest which i did not get
and i uh i thought about like
fighting over this just out of principle
because i love petty [__] so i feel like
the idea is really you know do not pay
obviously is getting really big it's
like the unbundling of do not pay
and it's taking this idea and it's like
okay i'm gonna run a bunch of google ads
against like getting security deposit
back florida getting security deposit
back california
and i think there's a big business to be
created here because then that's a
that's a good wedge to sort of expand a
bunch of different services
and i think there's the other version i
think we've once said which was like
uh call my politician there's all these
things where it's like ah this bill
could get passed that's bad for crypto
holders make sure you call your
politician and let them know you don't
want this it's like uh i don't know
i don't want to call my politician and
like who
what if they pick up what am i going to
say
like there's like there's all kinds of
problems with this idea of calling i
don't like calling
what happens if they pick up you know i
really want to go down that road but i
would happily you know sort of tip you
know 10 bucks to just have someone annoy
the [__] out of my politician about this
issue that i care about um like if my
donation funded like 18 annoying calls
like if there was just a website that
said would you like to donate 10 to the
cause and that will fund 18 annoying
phone calls from sri lanka to this
politician i'd be like [__] yeah put me
down for 20. and so i think that's the
other version of do not do not pay is
like go hassle for me
that's awesome i'm on board with that
can you what else you got greg my other
one
it relates to law actually a little bit
so
you know we've been
and then sean i know you're into crypto
um so i've been spending a lot of money
on
you know crypto accounting and crypto
law firms
um
and i think that there's an opportunity
to create a web three
crypto accounting firm and a web three
uh
crypto
uh law firm but all you have to do is
basically you find an existing law firm
that understands securities law and
you're like hey
you know you your shop of 10 lawyers and
you're like
you know you understand securities a law
maybe there's some you know
up leveling in terms of learning
specifics about nfts etc
i'm going to be the like marketing
engine for you you know use things like
the milk road and use things like lay
check out
and
i'm going to
send you leads
so the customer is happy because they're
like wow this is like a web 3 related
you know law firm and i want to work
with someone who's what does that mean i
don't know what you're using you're
using words that i don't have no idea
what they mean what does a web 3 related
law firm mean
okay so
let's just say you're creating an nft
project but you want to make sure that
you don't go to jail
so
let you don't do any sec violations
do you feel comfortable calling up your
regular lawyer who
might not even know what an nft is or
would you specifically want to talk to
a law firm
that lives and breathes web three
it depends if they have um what's like
for example if i what's the term if i
follow something my lawyer says and
they're supposed to be the expert
and i get in trouble sometimes i can
like blame them
what's that called
god i can't remember that i can't
remember but scapegoating
no it's like a it's like it's like when
you hire a c
it's like when you hire a c if you hire
a cpa and your cpa screws you like
blatantly sometimes you're not always
you you can
you know that goes
you're taking to account like ah dude i
thought he was doing it right he's a cpa
so like your cpa can actually get in
trouble not necessarily you so it
depends if that lawyer has that but i
don't know i'd rather just go to a legal
for a lawyer that special yeah that
specializes in this thing but i don't
know why you'd call it a website he's
describing it but he's had a web three
the law firm
yeah like they specialize and they they
know the laws around they specialize in
i think you meant like around this web
three not a digital law firm yeah okay
yeah all this is is like i mean this is
a marketing challenge more than anything
and
you know
one of the hardest problems about
running a law firm is you know or an
accounting firm is getting clients
and we talked about this with the
agencies the same thing is true with you
know law firms and accountancy firms i
think you know i don't know the like i
don't know the margins of some of these
businesses but i imagine they're quite
big
um so i think there's something there
so i considered doing this with my
before i did the milk road i was like
all right what do i want to do like i
got this audience that's growing right
it's like twitter's twitter's pretty big
now it's like i got a quarter million
followers newsletter's growing i could
just like you know
make no money off this that's fine how
big was your new ads in the newsletter
that's
what's that how big was the newsletter
it was like at 30 40k or something at
the time i could put something in there
yeah before milk
and uh and i was like i could teach a
course so i did that i taught a course i
was like all right that's cool it makes
way more money than ads but it's more
effort
and then i was like you know
what's like the highest value business
what's like the best [__] business
and i was like so i started making a
list of like places where i spend a lot
of money that i feel like they're just
kind of like rinse and repeating the
same stuff for me
um and so i i narrowed it down to two
i'll give you the second best one was
accounting um and i was like i could
just start a bookkeeping firm
for
uh for startups and entrepreneurs
just in my own portfolio if i invested
in 45 companies last year
just within that i bet i could get 14
clients of just companies that don't
have a bookkeeper because most companies
don't have bookkeepers
you were considering starting a
bookkeeping service that's like the
worst idea boring thing i could do for
you
that's a horrible idea because i was
just gonna be the marketing front end i
wasn't gonna operate it i was just gonna
buy or hire like a good bookkeeper and
be like cool
you're going to do the books and i'm
just going to send you clients and you
just close the clients and we split this
50 50 or whatever
and um so that was one idea the better
idea is insurance because insurance is
like the best business of all time
and because for insurance you don't even
really do insurance you just
broker the insurance with another like
carrier basically
and um and most businesses don't have
most like especially like e-commerce
businesses you need business insurance
and you don't know like i didn't know
exactly which insurance i needed how
much uh how much coverage i wanted
most traditional insurance firms don't
cover e-commerce which is insane to me
and so i was like all right well i could
just do that and so that was another one
which is you know startup slash
e-commerce insurance was another one i
basically did the math and i was like i
could make so much more money doing that
than if i ever did like ads in my
newsletter if all i did in my ad would
say hey by the way don't go to jail you
should have a bookkeeper you know like
hey um don't lose your business because
somebody you know whatever
chokes on a button
what was your match
what would your mat
first of all i think that's i think you
made 100 the right move doing what you
did because those businesses do not fit
your skill set or mine at all of like
it sure like that like being on top of
things like crazy amounts sweating the
details
i'm
all right so what was your math behind
it
i don't know i have to pull up all the
spreadsheets but basically just with my
existing audience size i think they
netted out whereas like i could be
easily clearing you know three to five
million dollars uh a year in profit if i
like kind of like hit all my marks tell
me more about this is actually really
full capacity this is actually really
interesting so what are we going to call
it like sean surrents
what was the name it's gonna be
something i don't know
the name was the last thing on my mind
okay so i even talked to the i had this
one one accountant who i really love
there's this like ukrainian woman who's
like this like amazing account she was
the first accountant i talked to that
felt like they worked for me and not
like as a they weren't just like a narc
and so they were like she was like have
you thought about this you know like
does your business need a vehicle
because i think right now just last week
of the year if you just bought a vehicle
we can actually like depreciate that and
use that against your books here like
she was giving me ideas that were
completely legal but she wasn't just
sitting there and saying yeah if you
give me all your paperwork and your
receipts i'll i'll file your taxes for
you it was the first person who was
saying wow you're paying a lot in taxes
over here and over here
um let me just make sure i'm you know
saving you money and so that was the
first person so i was going to basically
talk to her and be like hey should you
do this
like do you want to do this do you want
to like leave start your own firm i'm
sure you're scared of all that but guess
what uh you just do the things you're
really good at which is doing people's
you know like tax strategy and
accounting and i will get you all the
clients that was you know the core
premise but of course i i went down i
said i created a free crypto newsletter
uh because i just figured it'd be more
fun dude i think these are great ideas
by the way i think you made the right
decision but these are actually this is
crazy interesting i wish you would have
told me that you're can i tell you about
a [__] genius idea that came out of
that so
um have you i don't know if you've ever
like onboarded well like you've probably
done some onboarding with some some
software that you're trying to use or
some company you're trying to use so for
example with this with this bookkeeping
company right the one i hired i
eventually hired for my ecommerce thing
they sent me this like super long
checklist it was like all right um great
excited to work with you do these 54
things and then we'll get started like
that will be the start of your journey
that'll get you to the starting line
it's like
go to shopify give us access to do that
you need to go to view accounts
permissions add us there add us as a
bookkeeper blah blah blah now go to
quickbooks do the same thing now go to
stripe do the same thing now go to bank
of america do the same thing like there
was just all these [__] steps it's
like then sent us this then sent us this
and it just felt and it was all done in
excel right
so i discovered this
basically
takes that process it just
wraps beautiful user experience around
it and i saw it and i was like this is
so smart i invested in instantaneously
didn't have a meeting with the founder i
was like i totally buy it in fact any
word you say is only going to make me
less bullish on this idea because i am
already convinced this is one of the
best ideas i've ever seen so it's called
doc so it's doc.us i don't know if you
guys have checked this out
um
and uh julian julian shapiro sent this
to me after i was like
seeing this problem and then
coincidentally he sent me the same idea
so so here's how it works so basically
it just creates like kind of like a
notion space so the company who's trying
to onboard you they just create this
thing that's like it's like this is just
a beautiful experience that's like hey
sean so glad to have you on board first
three things we need to do are these
three click the check box when you're
done with them so i'll know that you did
it if you have any questions just put it
in the comment thing here or click this
to watch our tutorial from our library
that we have about how to do it and so
it just turns that like back and forth
email or like excel spreadsheet like um
janky thing into like
like workflow for a client
and um and a service to like onboard
each other
and i was like dude that's a problem
that like i don't know like i don't know
two million businesses a year have with
every one of their clients
this is gonna work i think this is gonna
work what do you guys think of this idea
really well i love it i just i just got
a mortgage um after my landlord
stiffness and
you know i go onto chase's website and i
don't know if you've done this but you
go a gun chase website you go to a
mortgage and there's like a thousand
things to do plus you're like
transported back to 1996 because you're
in this like weird thing there's like
javascript breaking everywhere there's
like
you like forgot about flash and like
flashes somehow in there
uh my my my uh
banker calls me and just like you didn't
finish this one thing and i was like
what she's like i added it to your
client portal it's like dude i don't get
a notification i don't know i don't go
check that i hate that place i [__]
hate that place yeah so
yes yes this is one of those no-brainer
ideas i i hope that they they actually
embed like create an sdk they do okay
i i i think that i don't know if they
already do or they're going to but that
was like a big part of yeah i was like
this can live inside of your app or
whatever so you know you
uh you could just kind of like onboard
people right there inside their
experience this landing page is
beautiful this is a beautiful website
yeah so
it is absolutely beautiful but i have a
question for you for you guys um because
it relates actually to this and also jim
shark and even the the lawyer stuff
which is
you know
sometimes when we're creating businesses
you can do one of two things you can
either
like create something brand new which is
like this
um or create like a new gym like a new
way of you know doing something or you
could like help existing people you know
do some marketing make some money that
way
do you guys you know and the silicon
valley way is is very much like go raise
a bunch of money invent something new
um and it's really frowned upon to do
you know the marketing piece of it and
sort of positioning on top of it um what
are your thoughts and you know do you
think about that a lot you know because
i've been thinking about it a lot
say it again give us two examples i'll
give you an example
so
um
you know
my last company the founder of 24 hour
fitness invested in my company and he
told me that before the 1980s
there
weren't membership based gyms like it
was a new thing
um
and he invented the first one and it
became 24-hour fitness i think they sold
for three or four billion dollars it was
a major success and then there's a lot
of people who copied membership based
gyms
that's an idea of going zero to one
creating an absolutely new product
whereas what he could have done
was created a gym shark of that era or
whatever and consulted gymlock yeah
exact jim long sorry
um and consulted to
you know
add additional revenue to existing
you know trainers etc
um so the question is do you know how
often you are thinking about creating
something brand new
versus you know
just kind of a money making
additional marketing layer on top of
sam what do you think about that
i don't
think i think of it
anything that i think of
i don't think any of it's brand new
i think zero
is close to zero i think about that do
you agree sean
um
no i think there's sometimes new things
but it's extremely rare extremely rare
extremely extremely rare but i would
even argue that most anything that's new
you could probably actually say oh well
it's just like a different version of
blank you could trace back right so like
let's take a airbnb for example airbnb
was clearly like kind of like this
breakthrough product became this huge
success
and it's like the category killer the
category leader for
sharing economy and whatever
um and now it's like bigger than hotels
like than all hotels or whatever so it
started off as a fringe thing but there
was like couch surfing before that and
like that was like a product that did a
very similar thing
um
you know and vrbo and there was there's
other stuff that's like around it so i
think you're right that it's very hard
to do something completely original but
let me frame it slightly differently
which is it seems like what greg is
almost saying is like
do you want to go for
uh try to try to have either a new
behavior or an existing behavior or
another way of looking at it would be
um
do you want to create a product or do
you want to have a service company right
like it's kind of to me that in those
examples is like 24 fitness was a new
was like a new product you needed
customers to go buy
versus
servicing you know
trainers and and whatever whoever else
um that was that's like a service
business that's going to have great cash
flow and doesn't require you to have
this like
winning brand and new product and new
customers from scratch is that is that
kind of is it more about the
services versus product is that the yeah
exactly yeah i think um you know sean
and
um sam like you know having spent time
in sf i feel like when i got to sf i was
all about
new behaviors
um that was really important to me and
sean i know that was true for you too
because like blab you're always pushing
you know the envelope with like
you know
and bebo it's like new you know
user interfaces and like
new
friend finding and new just like new
ways of doing things versus
now that we're in our 30s
it feels like we're doing less and this
is just an observation
and correct me if i'm wrong but it feels
like we're doing less of like the new
behavior type stuff
and more of like hey let's just like
iterate on this thing and like focus it
on this niche and
and do that there's this guy named roger
dickey i don't know him i think sean
knows him right
i never met him i think greg actually
knows him oh right so
i don't entirely know his full
background but he used to do like a
bunch of high-tech stuff he i know that
he had the uh what's the startup that
helps you code stuff it's like a new age
new agency what's it called those are
the g gixxer
get gigster okay and before giggster
greg what was he doing he was doing
something like very traditional silicon
valley right
i just know him from twitter but yes he
was doing uh he was the co-founder and
ceo of giggster which was
which was huge but he did it through a
really interesting way i think he did it
through a search lab do you guys know
what a search lab is yeah
and but i think before that like he
maybe was that zynga or something like
like a like he made like a mafia game or
something like that yeah like something
he made awards
which at the time was cutting edge now
his latest business i think it's called
revolution is it called revolution made
made made made and they are renovating
bathrooms and as a recent homeowner who
needs a new bathroom i went to the
website and i was like this is sick i
love this i bid and it looks from the
outside like the company is just
crushing it i saw another guy the guy
who started casper his name's luke uh
one of the four founders his name's luke
i think he has a new business that's
also renovating bathrooms or maybe
kitchens and i thought it was
interesting that these guys casper not
exactly like cutting edge but kinda like
kind of new behavior buying a mattress
online uh
roger dickey you know
definitely new behaviors they're going
to like these like older businesses and
they're definitely using technology but
at the end of the day they're not like
re they're not inventing anything new
they're just inventing maybe a a more
efficient process and in my opinion
those things are far more interesting
and it's kind of intriguing to me that
these guys are doing that as opposed to
some
new cutting edge thing
so so i'll give you my my take on your
on your question greg which is
uh in my 20s it's like the way i
traveled was i'd be like oh
you know [__] it i'll go tomorrow i'll
spin the globe put my finger down all
right i'm gonna go backpacking through
you know eastern europe or i'm gonna go
to australia and i'll be you know
sleeping in a van type of thing and i
wanted the adventure it was actually the
right move to do at that time because
it's like how do you get max adventure
max sort of like discomfort and like out
of your comfort zone you know max
spontaneity all that stuff and um and
then like now it's like where's like a
sandals resort that i could take my kids
and like you know i i just want to sit
down i just want a place i can go sit
that's not my house
this is basically the extent of my
adventure right now and so similarly
like that's my hope my business career
was the same it was like at the
beginning it's like yo i'm going to
build the next social network i'm going
to build a a dating app where you you
know you might die or whatever this is
like these crazy ideas it's like every
idea was like trying to be crazier than
the last it's like you know and it all
appealed to me that way and now i'm like
cool i could um
sell a product that i you know let me
import a product from china and sell it
through a facebook ad i click three
buttons i can just sit in my chair and
do that i don't really need a staff i
don't really you know i'll just kind of
outsource this and that all i was gonna
write a newsletter um and i'll just
write it in my browser and then that's
it uh like i don't have to like become
the next mark zuckerberg i just need to
get to like
enough people where i'm making a few
million dollars a year and live in a
sweet lifestyle um like that's that's a
win you know and that's and i don't have
to manage anybody and i don't have to
like stress out about this thing and i
don't have to know how to code i don't
have to know any of these things oh yeah
great and so i basically am now in the
the sort of sandals resort part of my
career and i mean that in the best way
possible which was
back then
i was like almost like
intrigued by the degree of difficulty
and now
i'm completely put off by the degree of
difficulty and instead i just do the
thing that sounds like what's gonna be
easy simple fun for me and um and you
know i'm just gonna go that route and so
i am much less interested in like
inventing the next big thing as i am
like
crafting a dope lifestyle doing
something i enjoy
and like me feels like but do you think
that's gonna change when your kids get
older so when your kids become eight
nine ten maybe eight to like
16. they think that you are the coolest
guy ever or if they don't think that
maybe it's on the other end of you
wanting to think that you're cool and
you want to impress them
um and i've been thinking a lot about
that lately i'm like do i think that my
attitude will change when my kids become
five six seven eight and i want to
impress them do i think like instead of
just like having a sick lifestyle i'd be
like oh man i want to do something like
that they are proud of do you think
that's going to change
not because of that reason i do think
it's going to change but not because of
that like uh i don't think your kids
think you're cool based on like
your business success necessarily i
don't i don't really think that that's
the main the main way that kids think
you're cool um
and even if it was that's not why i
would do something um i would just have
more free time right like when my kids
go to school that's gonna be like a
[__] game changer it's like i'm gonna
get a third of my day back uh that i you
know i don't have today and so when they
go to school i have a lot more bandwidth
if i want to do something more intense i
can ratchet up the intensity and the
difficulty level if i so choose uh at
that time right now like dude before i
do this podcast
like i'm not uh i'm not like
you know
researching every detail for the 20
minutes before this podcast typically
i'm like reading this book called
goofy's adventure to my daughter putting
her down for the nap you know like
that's how i prep for this product 20
minutes before is like i'm literally
reading disney books putting my daughter
to bed in time to come back out here
right so it's like there's a lifestyle i
like right now that's doing this and so
i'm optimizing for that i think in five
years i'm gonna be picking a very
different challenge than i'm picking
today
just because it'll be time for another
chapter and i'll probably be like oh
that lifestyle shit's boring i want to
go do something big or i'm going to be
like
[__] business business is stupid i'm
going to go like
try to write a comedy show and i'm going
to like try to sell a show for tv like i
don't know i'm gonna do something else
with my life
every five years i want to kind of
reinvent myself in terms of what i'm
doing so
you've come a long way sean
so
one of the first times i met you
you invited me to the bibo launch party
and i invite i was like could i bring a
plus one you're like sure
i bring this friend who's visiting
and we walk into this warehouse or
something in san francisco i remember we
had to like walk upstairs and like where
was it sean
it was in a uh you know like a car
manufacturer car uh repair yeah like
like a garage just like for car repairs
whatever i don't know i forgot how to
speak english but like basically michael
had bought one of those
like got rid of all the like car
maintenance stuff and just turned it
into like his man cave and he hadn't
filled it up yet with his his like fancy
cars and cool [__] yet so it's just an
empty warehouse in the middle of san
francisco downtown san francisco and we
threw our launch party there before he
filled in so i'm there with one of my
buddies from this small town in quebec
the guy has never left his town
basically in his entire life so he had
landed san francisco he's staying with
me he gets into this you know
car shop or whatever and it's like dark
and there's smoke and there's lights
everywhere and then you walk in and
there's all these people
and there's lights everywhere and he
like literally whispered to me and he
said is kanye west coming to this
[Laughter]
did he say yeah
he should have said yeah
and
it was like one of those moments like
i'm sure a bunch of people have like
watch
the social network when it's like justin
timberlake is like talking to uh
i guess it's mark zuckerberg in the club
and it's just like
it's intense and it's like larger than
life and you were kind of like living
that
lifestyle in san francisco not like i
mean i'm painting you as very playboy
and i won't say you're 100 playboy but
um in the sense of like you were living
that lifestyle you were you were doing
that like zuckerberg thing
and now
um
you're you know you're kind of doing the
complete opposite and my question to to
to actually both of you
but particularly for sean
is if you could redo it would you have
done more
more of these product bets that are
uh there's it's really less risk like
for example milk road like
there wasn't that much risk there yeah
yeah let's be right here right so like i
feel like people like we're
now that we're in our 30s we're focusing
on different niches
and we're taking things that are working
different communities and we're just
pushing that out there with you know low
product risk would you have done that or
do you think that you needed to do these
crazy bets in your 20s
to to to be where you are today
i have a very easy answer but i'll let
sean go first
no no go no i want you to go first i
want to hear what you're going to say
playboy sean well i was playing bullshot
by the way for that i flew in this
painter that i had met and he did i
don't remember this he did a live
painting where he he's painting this
like abstract thing he's break dancing
while he's doing it and this is a guy i
had seen at a at a fair and greely
colorado many years before that and i
was like hey dude i have like a
like i have a company that has like a
bunch of funding like you want to just
like fly out for this party and do
something dope do that thing you did at
that little town fair do it in front of
like hundreds of people at this thing
and he's doing it and then at the end he
spins the canvas and what looks like
this crazy abstract thing was he had
painted like a [__] bob marley upside
down
and it's like he does this like whatever
he flips the thing and then he's like
done and he slaps it with his hand it's
full of paint and it was like that was
the moment and i was just like that
party was dope that was a dope party
actually now that i remember it so do i
regret it well now that i'm thinking
about that party no i don't regret it
that was pretty awesome
i'm glad i did it because i'm happy with
where i am now having said that there
were so many things that i did foolishly
during that time and i'm not just
talking about like
you know oh you know i wasn't as good at
this thing as i am now it's like no like
there was so much opportunity right
under my nose
and i was blind to it and like one of
the biggest like scary things for me now
is like
what are those things today
that are right in front of me that i'm
too stupid to see just like i was too
stupid to see it seven years ago when i
was doing that other thing
um for example
greg you were in our early mastermind
groups and the founders of calm were
there and they were talking about how
hard it was and how they're just you
know it was just alex it was just kind
of like
yeah it's hard to raise money right now
i'm trying and and we were just like
dude it's cool app man you should stick
with it he's like yeah i'm gonna just
keep going and like that's a 2 billion
dollar plus company now and we were
helping him like
dude why didn't we cut the check you
were there too i don't know you didn't
cut a check either did you i i remember
at the time like if i'm being honest
like i felt that it was too niche like i
was like we were like sean you and i
were focusing on like
we were doing big stuff stuff that was
going to be yeah exactly
later
he's got the huge company
uh there was so many of those so in our
masterminds itself i think uh loom was
in there that's a billion dollar company
and i remember kind of like trying to
mentor shy and being like
bro like you know that don't worry
you'll figure it maybe it's not this one
but like when you get to your real game
you're gonna be like good because of
this experience you were friends with
him too like did you invest in that like
i missed i missed it was called uh uh
what was it called open test dot co
and that's what loom was originally and
it you know
it felt like
you know when you're doing your first
startup and
it just feels so shaky because you're
it's your first time doing all this
stuff like that's what
it felt like and so it was
you know and then also the the narrative
at the time was
don't invest in other people's startups
you got if you if you want to make it in
silicon valley you got to give
laser focus so i you know my mistake
in my 20s was i came to san francisco
and
you know i listened to all these vcs
with all their narratives
and i did it and if i were to redo it i
would frankly just be doing what i now
which is doing like what i'm doing now
which is like focused on communities
doing agency services
you know
focusing on niches and and and web you
know yeah just build an experiment and
not have the biggest exits in the world
so there was like 10 examples like that
like i remember alex mccall came over
one day and he we were catching up and
then
he went on to start clear i remember
thinking this guy's [__] amazing
i should invest in this clear bit thing
and i like went over to his office and
we like hung out i was like about to
meet the guys i was like i love the
energy of this office man like if i just
couldn't do anything besides feel this
office i would be like they're building
a winner in here and that's also like i
don't know if it's a billion it's
multi-million dollar company
um and he told me at the end he goes oh
by the way i'm buying up uh
i was like what else are you doing
finally i started asking smart questions
like what else are you doing he's like
oh i bought up some stripe shares this
stripe share is available for like two
billion dollars so i'm buying a bunch of
striped shirts i think it was him maybe
josh buckley is one of them and he's
like i'm buying up stripes for 2 billion
let me know if you want in
and i was like 2 billion to me i was
like well that's like the most a startup
is worth is like a billion is like the
top of the mountain so like
to me it was like oh there's no upside
left you know i didn't like think from
first principles about like everybody
knew stripe was [__] amazing it was
like the best startup in the whole like
you know in silicon valley
and i had this opportunity to go buy
stripes at 2 billion and i thought how
late i was and i was like man i wish i
could have got in earlier and now like
you know the things i would give for
stripe shares at 2 billion now like
it's like
that's already like
like 100x you know from from there and
that was proven right
forget that then there was all the
services we were using like furcon who's
my cto he'd be like oh this is a cool
cool product let's use this in our tech
stack
if i had just invested in all the bills
we were paying for like software we were
using like pagerduty and elasticsearch
and so you know like one after another
those were all
huge winners that were pre-ipo
um so first was investing the second was
like project selection so like you were
talking about greg i did the same thing
i was playing by the rules of like i was
playing by other people's rules
meaning like what was considered cool in
silicon valley was to be like a product
guy
who was building who had like cool
product taste and was building like um
you know like new markets and like going
for the big billion dollar prizes
and then i met sam who was like i'm
writing this newsletter it's free i'm
gonna have like newsletter ads and i was
like yeah but like
are you gonna do a startup someday
like that's how i felt about it right
sam's company
sells for more than more than my company
sold for in the end he goes uh he goes
look you're good but basically like
you're showing up to a knife fight with
a knife and i wish you would show up
with a magic wand that would just murder
the competition i'm like sounded cool
right i was like uh that's a great
analogy that's a cool story but like uh
[Music]
i don't know man i think
the math kind of i think it might
achieve the desired outcome which i'm
trying to do here which
uh when i started i was just trying to
be financially independent by the age of
30. that was the only goal um and so
so like if i could go back and just
whisper three things about like just
just strategy like forget life advice
just strategy advice i would have said
um
invest in all the smart people you know
like it'll it'll work out if you don't
have the money go convince somebody that
you have a bunch of really smart friends
that they should give you money to
invest in that that'll be the first
thing the second is invest in all of the
expenses on your p l so go find all the
places you're spending money and go try
to invest in all those companies that
will also do fantastically well you'll
make more on that than your own company
okay if you really want to do your own
company beyond that fantastic that's
great you're going to build up skills
and you got a lottery ticket there that
might work i would have just said
like don't try to be mark zuckerberg
from the social network like think about
what like like basically just open your
eyes to the problems and the
opportunities that exist today and so
like
you know whether it was like e-commerce
or shopify apps or like these sounded
small at the time but they sounded small
because that's where they were early
and like at that time i needed a vc to
like stamp their approval that this was
a good market or a good opportunity
which by that time is pretty late
because what's the vc doing they're
looking at what companies are raising
huge rounds which means like
four years ago those were great
opportunities three years ago those were
great opportunities and so i wish i had
just kind of been more eyes wide open on
like
what projects are available to you and
like the things that sound kind of
nation funny
those are actually better signals for
you than the thing that the vc is saying
is going to be huge or is already huge
because it's
often um
you know those companies to start are
like you're in a you're in an absolute
dog fight and it's just like one winner
out of 100 is going to emerge versus
other things where like you could
basically take
um no no product risks no market risk so
i had a friend vishal tell me this once
he goes i invest in companies with no
product market fit risk
i had never heard somebody say that it
didn't even make sense to me i go what
do you mean like
every startup is product market fit risk
you guys know it's not
like what he goes
he was the one who convinced me to buy
bitcoin initially as well he was like
bitcoin's going to be the you know the
biggest thing in the world he's like i
just put up basically all the money i
have in the bitcoin i was like what the
[__] this is like back in 2016 15.
nobody was really saying that back then
so for the product market fit thing he
goes he goes for example i just invested
in a company that's making a robot that
makes pizzas and it makes pizza it makes
a perfect pizza every time 24 7 at a
lower cost than a human being can do it
he goes
i don't know if they can because there's
a ton of engineering risk like they may
not be able to technically do it but if
they can do it there's zero market risk
every pizza shop will want this over
paying an employee to make imperfect
pizzas
only in certain hours call in sick and
blah blah like it for a higher cost
and i was like oh [__] that's true there
are things that have zero market risk
and i was taking like maximum market
risk before so like that's the other
strategy is like
you don't have to take as much market
risk the thing you're doing now greg is
like way less market risk the thing i'm
doing with milk road had like zero
market risk basically and there's just
like there's a lot of money there's
life-changing money that can be made and
a lot of fun that can be had without
taking on unnecessary what happened to
that pizza company
i think they're still in engineering
risk mode they got like a big contract
from domino's but then their ceo got
was in trouble for some things that they
hired a new ceo something something
something
you know like again these are legit
engineering risks so i'm not like that
doesn't mean they'll all work
but like what i'm doing with the
newsletter is like neither technical
risk nor market risk yeah operational
risk it's just are you gonna are you
gonna be able or wanting to do it for a
long time which is
yeah you know that's a pretty good thing
to try to overcome
right yeah it's really tough you know i
remember coming to san francisco and
and hearing all these narratives and
these bc's telling me this and also
entrepreneurs sort of repeating a lot of
this stuff
and i will say it
it's tough to go against
what
these stamps of approvals say to do you
know like you have to tell yourself
every day like and i have to do that too
like when i started a services business
all my most of my silicon valley friends
were like a services business like an
agency
that's what you're gonna do
after you know like and you just kind of
have to push forward and really just um
remember that
you know just because some you know
certain people on twitter say a certain
thing or or sequoia or andreessen say a
certain thing doesn't mean
um
you can't have a great like i would say
you can have a better lifestyle not
being mark zuckerberg than being mark
zuckerberg
yeah
exactly
the pope catholic bro a brown bear shits
in the woods
right obviously
yeah what was that a brown bear shit's
in the woods yeah
that's a sampard special
that's a vampire special
is that the number seven sample
specialty i just ordered because i think
i got it
the brown bear [__] in the woods yeah
that's why people listen to this podcast
though for a couple of sam's parts and
sample specials
did you just what did you say did i did
i just order a sambar smartphone number
seven because i think i just got it yeah
that's good by the way uh there i made a
joke recently
where shawn you go yeah so there's these
short traders and i said oh yeah how
tall is he and you just like
totally skipped by it and the people in
the comments on youtube were like
i think the joke was funny but it was
definitely funny that shawn just ignored
him
no people were like dude how did you not
acknowledge that absolute gem on time on
target you were you were quick with that
one yeah it got no love and the
commenters uh
pointed it out
you're the new chris rock man you're the
new chris rock you're a better version
of chris rock
thank god this is digital he's gonna
[__] slap me right in the face
dude i can't believe that happened i'm
gonna like right after this i'm gonna go
see i can't wait to see uh will smith
apologize
oh yeah he's for sure gonna come up with
something by the way the form on his
slap if you look at the photo
full extension crossbody i mean like do
you i've never slapped anyone if i tried
to stop someone once i'm not gonna have
perfect form that guy
has to have slapped before because
you don't just wake up with perfect form
on a slap like that like the just look
at the extension and tell me that's not
the best
12 000 smith is a habitual slapper man
he's a perfectionist this guy is slapped
before we gotta we gotta stop this guy
before he gets out of control i wonder
he's definitely slapped before i wonder
as he was walking up
the catwalk there was like five seconds
there so i wonder what he was thinking
like was he like you know what am i
gonna punch him am i gonna slap him like
i wonder what was going through his mind
i think he's always rocker a little
right now
i've done that before to my sister where
like i knew i was mad and i started to
charge she's five years older than me so
i was like you know a kid at the time
and i knew i was mad and i had i had a
i have to do something but i had no plan
and so i had like three steps to
improvise the plan i remember this and
she'll she always tells the story we
were in the kitchen and i was pissed
because she made fun of me and i'm five
six years old and i was walking
and i am in the kitchen i just grab a
butter knife
and i go nisha this is the end
that was my statement and like she was
like the end of what i was like
like nobody knows what happened after
that we both just blacked out she
thought it was hilarious that i
you know said like a movie line like a
loser and i was holding this butter
knife i don't know what i was going to
try to do but uh it wasn't going to work
she was she could overpower me pretty
handily at that time
special
all right that's the episode by the way
greg you said something
don't edit yet i want to leave with with
with greg got my wheels turning even
while we're joking my wheels are still
turning about what you just said about
the narrative
here's my challenge each of us
what's one narrative that you think
actually you should be going counter to
that narrative
like there's a narrative that we hear as
entrepreneurs as people in kind of tech
and like what do you think is the like
actually i don't know
maybe it's this other thing instead so
if anyone has one do it but i otherwise
i'll i'll give you one
yeah go for it so
mine would be um
i'll give you two there's the inside
crypto there's a narrative that's
basically like oh there's all this
innovation happening this
it's like the next protocol the next
token the next whatever
i'm pretty sure that if you just buy
three or four things like if you buy
bitcoin eth um i put luna in there now
just buy those three
and you just chill either all of crypto
is gonna work and those will work
amazingly
or crypto's not gonna work and no matter
what you did like if those fail if those
don't go up dramatically in value
um crypto just didn't work and none of
this [__] will work and so i think
actually a basically like
for a while the best strategy was
bitcoin and chill and now it's ethan
chill i basically think it's still the
same i think it's like buying two or
three tokens and not even needing to
know anything more just chilling on
those is probably the best investment of
the next like 10 to 15 years gonna
outperform everything during that time i
so i think like
going deeper down the rabbit hole and
like learning more is actually going to
[__] up your returns versus just buying
the the main ones and just holding for
for like 10 years not thinking about it
that's one and then the other is
i think that angel investing doesn't
make much sense anymore and i say this
as somebody who angel invests
like the valuations are so high
um that like if i think about like that
same money going into like one of these
sort of boring cash flow businesses is
so much better for your life so if
you're like an individual angel investor
and you have let's say a hundred
thousand dollars
you know or three hundred thousand
dollars that you want to go put into
like a basket of 20 startups
it's like are you sure you shouldn't
just buy like
like get an sba loan and go buy like
some random website that's already
producing profit and that'll pay itself
off in two years or less and uh and now
you own this cash flowing asset like i'm
pretty sure that's just gonna do better
dude i
agree than a basket of angel investments
the the the
our friends who have all crushed it on
angel investing you know it means they
made their investments five or eight
years ago and it was different it is
it's outlandish at the moment so i agree
with that i think for mine that i think
that it's actually
i think that
i think that you only have a few swings
in your career and a lot of people are
like oh you should be patient and you've
got a lot of time to do certain stuff i
actually think you should try you should
dedicate your 20s to getting your first
significant win
because after that life gets a lot
harder you get a lot less energy you're
a lot smarter which is actually bad you
actually it's kind of good to be kind of
ignorant
um and not enough people i think all
often times people go the other route
where they go well just go join
something for a little while and learn
in my opinion f that your 20s dedicated
to getting a win and getting even if
it's relatively small and do it as fast
as possible because after that life is a
lot easier
i'll give my
what sean
i was going to say give the moyes quote
about getting rich quick he goes why
does everyone hate on getting rich quick
get rich quick schemes are the best
i want to get rich quick i don't want to
get rich slow
i got i got two real quick
so i
got off the phone with a friend of mine
who worked at facebook he told me this
morning he told me that he works
roughly 90
90 to 120 minutes per day
on average
i thought you're gonna say 90 to 120
hours a week he yeah it's the best when
you measure your work in minutes he's
texting me he texted me today he said it
was 9 12 a.m he said 9 12 a.m finish
work for the day
12 12 minutes
and so
you know put us in a group chat i want
him to text us every day just the time
stamp of winning so that's what that's
what i told him to do i said you need to
create like a twitter a non account a
twitter that's and so i'm gonna
stay tuned do that um but i think that
in your 20s
like
potentially go work at facebook go work
at google get those high paying jobs
i think that by the way i think i think
that's a good way to get a win get get
you know do that for a few years
while you're
you know do you're doing your you're
learning on the side like join a tao
build a community build a newsletter do
whatever you want to do it really speaks
to you
while you're you're not
you know
yeah so you're making money and you're
learning
what more could you ask for and then my
and you know just because you gave a
crypto
uh
one sean i think that and i spent a lot
of time in nft land and web 3 land too
i think that nfts are going to 99
freedom it it's going to be a free
freedom and thing i think the the idea
of selling nfts
uh
will be a very small thing
okay so what what happens why why would
i give away something for free or what's
my incentive so what happens after it's
freedom in so
yeah i mean you know okay so the idea
right now it's like people are selling
nfts and projects for 0.05 to 0.2 let's
say on average for some of these you
know 10 000 pfp projects
i think that um
that's going to burn out at some point
and i think we're starting to see it
burn out a little bit
and
i think that you know did you see the
hundred thieves drop
yeah they
uh what do they do exactly they did a
much smaller amount so they basically
first of all it was in gaming and gamers
hate nfts so the fact that they did a
successful gaming nft launch like
obviously kudos to them
but basically
they won this championship and they were
like okay in order to get this like
collectible you can go grab it it's free
we're not saying it's going to be worth
anything and they got 700 000 people to
collect this collectible
and
and there's like a trophy right and then
they make money on
if there's value right so if it grows in
value they get royalties
and i think that's what you're going to
see a lot of is like creators and and
big communities basically doing freedom
ins um
even though people
seem you know people today think that
selling nfts is the future i don't think
so
right
by the way i'm going to change mine to
just simplify it instead of starting a
company buy an existing business i think
that is the most overlooked obvious
thing for a smart person to do
is
how do you take your market risk to
essentially zero um
you buy a business that's already
working and profitable and you just say
cool i'm a better operator than this
person or i know about a different form
of operation than they do and so i can
grow this using facebook ads or i can
grow this using outsourcing or i can
grow this using you know code or
whatever it is
so
you you hear almost no narrative uh you
heard tons of narrative around
the genius visionary startup
start a new thing building a new project
launching a new thing and like
you hear like one or two examples of
people buying businesses
and i think that for most smart people
buying a business is a far better idea
than starting yeah but when you're in
your 20s
my pushback to that is like when you're
in your let's say early 20s like do you
know
like you're saying that now
but i think like yeah
um you do need like that operational
experience and that's where my point is
um you got to
like it's worthwhile to
to just
potentially take a high-paying job and
then on the side kind of like experiment
and do stuff
yeah that's true i'm not really
limiting mine to the 20s i think uh i'm
still making mistakes in my 30s so i'm
assuming other people are dude i guess
it's more like what narrative do i hear
now that's easy to float along with that
i'm like you know what actually
i don't i don't i just think this is
true and like that's the one for me
which is like for most people who want
to be entrepreneurial they
default to starting a business and i
think actually maybe it should be the
opposite maybe you should default to
taking on an existing business and
growing it and only create a new thing
if you like actually have a new
invention in mind a new idea that really
you can't shake in your head versus like
just starting a new startup i like that
because because you want to be an
entrepreneur right um
all right i think we lost sam we got to
go all right greg thanks for coming man
where should people find you twitter at
greg eisenberg or on our pod where it
happens
or uh in the mountains of canada or the
mountains of canada unless you're the
irs in which case he's in miami at least
180 days out at least
all right
[Music]
you